R Cronin the former head coach of Northeastern
University the AL matter of David Co this one
Center good save by Soros and the rebound blocked
by Cody glass and Dante Fabro to back he'll get
a shot block but watch SOS connect the dots
right in the middle find space look at the
eyes connected and then Cody glass helping
out rebound loose at the slot picked up by
Colton siss his first touch O'Reilly weighing the
option onetime Yosi W rebound off the backboard
cist had a look at it couldn't play it now
out of the box comes stro Strow oneon-one he
scores oh terrible break for the Predators just
as Str came out of the box they deal it to him and
he's able to beat Soros a shocking turnaround One
play R here miss shot just goes by siss and then
just lifted in the air by color goes perfectly
on the stick a nice little move here quick hands
opens up SOS look at it right there he's trying
to dig in and can't quite close up the pads quick
enough a stro deliv a generating offense good
defense those types of things have to be a little
more consistent within the group borberg lost
the handle picked up by Carrick got him in wide
open save made by Soros getting the pad down 10
shots on goal already this is his ninth save Lon
wide open ju ends with a mobile ID lot of good
times going there here's a shot by lome action
in front tipped in vrono got a stick on it and it
pinball pass Soros for a two nothing lead so the
Ducks allar doubles the lead for Anaheim right
in front and watch this deflection he's battling
in front there you see him he's ready for this
tip and just gets a piece of it for his 19th
goal of the season oh then it goes off mcdunn
it it tips off of vatrano MCD Troy Terry from
the circle draw assistance over now they work it
to The Far Side [Music] MAV they bring it back
to Terry he looks back door got it to mavage and
they score what a shot mavage a perfect short side
upper corner it's a power play goal for the Ducks
it's three nothing there's one two and this pass
right across look at that shot you can see there's
not much room there at all Saros is down he's got
the low part covered and right there he tries to
get his head over that's with just 13 wins on the
season but as we told you they're they've been
Scrappy they've been in so many games this one
off to the side of the net in the slot O'Reilly
fought off there by doall O'Reilly coming back
and here's a battle one right there guys just on
the for check cause a turnover and then look at
thomaso he sees O'Reilly there [Music] just who
clear The Zone let's see how Anaheim handles the
Lea as you mentioned M they're not a good scoring
team at all now here's a play right in front class
St Point Blank by doall wide here but look this is
the hustle we're talking about look at thomasino's
effort good deception there by McCarron on the
pass he's kind of looking shot and then right
there that P just goes off of nvi had come out
of the gates with a couple of good Faceoff wins
trying to turn the tables on that one and re works
his way down the fors at the half wall centers it
in front Terry right back door score that might
have gone off of Fabro two men down low with the
numbers Fabro sliding to try to take away the pass
but the ducks have made it four nothing this it's
just it's crazy this is just a pass kind of a
a blind pass across the net right here trying
to make the back door and then Fabro with the
stick he's trying to break this Terry's going to
stro and then Fabro right in the middle just right
through the wickets and then when it when it rains
it Pour put a couple together here Novak drops it
off evangelis to survey puts it towards the net
knocked down in front it's loose go off swing it
towards the net is Smith he put it in the blue ice
ducks with an aggressive four check here Nashville
having trouble getting out perier to Center Ice
thomasino drives it to the net on his back hand
save made rebound centered class got a piece of
FL save by dool and McCaron got a shot as well and
then he's got support he could see McCarron going
to the net doall then glass comes in and then this
one right here he's just down over wanted to see
what was coming in on the second wave it's lifted
out of there by Novak Here Comes Evangelista 2on
one he's got Yosi with him Evangelista save made
by doall fa angelista right here he's looking
shot all the way doall good glove save keep a no
look pass well anticipated by Lund that one got
around Evangelista good keeping glass the Novak
no look pass Evangelista back Tander stop rebound
thomasino looking for on the backside picked
up by glass he tried to center it out of the
box comes gutus and he takes it towards the net
gutus all the way in Saved by Soros Soros comes
out aggressively and he banked it in followed it
up and knocked it off of Soros and into the net
and that's the kind of night it's been the second
time the ducks have converted right after a power
play expires a player in this one right here Soros
comes out makes a big save there gives Gus nothing
to to shoot at and then look at this little Bank
off of his stick I think it's Evangelista right
here off his stick off soros's skate and in the
net working down look has his 19 go of the Year
tonight ran stro he's got a goal tonight onetime
rebound loose saved by Soros scramble behind the
net picked up by the Ducks over 30 seconds of
possession time for the ducks in a couple of
good chances Henri thr back side oh what a save
by sorrow his best of the nine and this is this
is probably the best chance of the hockey game
right now that the ducks have got funny enough
but watch this is a look at that Saros look at
the efficiency there he's got his right skate
look and just it's a half push but look at his
eyes connected to that he sees it hit the pad
all the way Terry comes right down the slot off to
the wing a lunging save by Soros Carrick lets it
Fly that's blocked by a diving ker up the ice NY
short-handed with ker ker gets in he's [Applause]
go it's from this team and no matter what
the situation is they compete and there's
look at that block right there and nqu comes
down he's waiting Kier is the one who blocked
the shot he gets up and continues down the ice
picks this up and just slides it five hole now
on a scrambled now and need to get the puck
back continuation lome just over the boards
drives in to get some tired player loose
in front great save by Soros inside the
blue ice and thearon trying to get a good hit
of his own there from mnov and then he drives
into the next guy they're going to let this
play go this is going to get some attention
goranov had a window but he lifted the
backand way too high aarron powering
his way down there Aaron making things happen
here's the shot they score thomasino delivers
poell a tremendous shift by Michael
McCaron this game and right here they
keep pucks alive and McCaron just battling
see no stick there and then McCarron just
nice little Fades out kind of a no look
little probably going to hit him right in
the chest there but he's able to see
that one Yosi once again Evangelista
a second time this one into sticks loose
Parson and popped up in the air [Music]
score it's a 53 Game Nashville all over the
place in front of the net and it looks like
it was Dennis gurianov sequence right here
do what you can do and look at McCarron he's
taking his eyes away looked back there doall
doesn't find this Puck and now it's just a
battle everyone just tapping that in and
Guana finally getting that to goal this
will be a good look and Gall just trying to
battle hits McCarron siss looking for bsor got
it wide and that'll do it so Nashville
ends up with 42 shots a furious rally